salut les menthe à l'eau aujourd'hui je
suis avec mon pote max salut max salut
maxi vous le connaissez pas ce qui
m'étonnerait
mais si vous le connaissez pas vous
pouvez déjà cliqué sur sa tête alain
dhée monde des idées reçues sur internet
tout à fait et alors aujourd'hui j'étais
invité pour parler de pippa ce qui est
une grande idée reçue sur pie sur le
nombre à l'appui je vois piper laurie
3,14 à l'intérieur toutes ces 10 mg à
l'idée reçue est ce que tu sais laquelle
non j'ai fait parce que je le dis est ce
que je fais semblant de savoir ou pas on
pense que c'est un nombre univers ce qui
veut dire qu'en fait dans toutes les
décimales de pi
il ya toutes les combinaisons possibles
de chez un nombre univers c'est ça c'est
un nombre qui a des décimales à l'infini
mais elles sont pas périodiques elles
sont pas cyclique
c'est comme si on fait 10 / 3 savez 3,3
trop trop trop trop trop trop trop
ressasser périodiques c'est cyclique ça
oui l'encyclique 3 puis trois puis
retrouvé exactement mais ça pourrait
être aussi 4 5 6 4 6 4 6 1 46 et dans un
nombre univers on peut retrouver toutes
les séquences possible il ya par exemple
votre âge avec mon âge avec le numéro de
carte bleue de mike byrd et aussi tout
le roman hamlet dedans c'est vrai il ya
même tout le roman hamlet mais avec
comme personnage principal
harry potter possibilités tu vois ce
qu'il sait mieux d'ailleurs
oui les gens je lirai plus mais oui il
ya aussi forcément un endroit où il ya
16 millions de zéro puisque possibilités
et 17 millions d'euros exactement c'est
horrible à souhait il perd gêneurs goal
com france et en fait ça veut dire qu'il
ya aussi le film le troisième film the
dark knight
la version avec heath ledger s'il était
pas moins examinons un jeu et si on
change si on change un pixel paraschiv
ya la joconde méga la joconde avec la
cicatrice de harry potter
ce qui serait encore mieux mais en fait
foi de tout le territoire lire partout
ça va ça marche donc on pressent que
pied comme ça mais il ya une idée reçue
où on lit souvent dans des dans des
magazines dans des revues même parfois
dans des revues scientifiques milliards
et que pi est un nombre univers on n'en
sait rien on le pressent on croit encore
à une bouteille reçu total c'est un
doute on le pressent c'est comme racine
de deux ans on pressent que c'est ça
mais on peut pas le prouver on en est
pas encore certain de manière là c'est
vraiment un doute un c'est pas et le
jour où on danse un certain ça changera
pas le calcul du cercles ou quoi que ce
soit
voilà ça ça marche ça marchera tout le
temps on va très bien imaginer couverte
une sortie demain il peut tout les
cherche sur des carrés on s'est fait mal
en fait les hommes ne peuvent pas voler
il ya un jeu qui s'organisait autour de
pis ça c'est fabuleux ce sont des
personnes qui apprennent les décimales
de pi s'organiser à prendre ça le record
du monde non validé c'est un japonais à
la retraite un ancien ingénieur il a
mémorisé 100000 décimales de pi la base
tomber je compté jusqu'à 100 milles
pendant 16 heures c'est déjà un exploit
alors retenir lors des en plus du coup
il ya aucune fin et biologiques avec ben
oui c'est ça qui est très drôle c'est
complètement irrationnel quoi et alors
c'est bon il n'a pas été validé par le
guinness book il est pas là toujours là
donc nous on va le faire je vous avais
16 heures j'espère bien que le guinness
vous le voit le valider parce que le mec
qui a été validé au guiness ses soixante
sept mille décimales sa ferme à jabot
mal ce qu'ils meurent a demandé jean
corneille genou droit c'est de me dire
la démarche coco en fait commente yves
jeanneret dans la vie c'est la période
68 mille décimale de classe a6 emile de
règles nil depuis jeanne rajouter mille
déjà ça me semble issue mais quel est le
quotidien d'apprentissage voilà cette
passion de ce mec j'ai pas parce que ça
ridicule
ah oui je vous en ridicule mais je
savais que si je jouais sa classe dans
le film d'ang lee le 17 pouces mais il
s'appelle pays dont tout le monde se
fout de sa gueule parce que pipi et pour
que les gens arrêtent dessous de sa
gueule mais il apprend par coeur et il
me bluffe tout le monde avec celle là
c'est moi perso j'ai appris les 10000
combien d'armes à sabres il est digne je
sais ça faudrait que ça me faisait
plaisir que tu me dises que ce soit
ridicule parce que c'est pas que c'est
ridicule
non en fait je vais mater sa salle du
tout ce que je veux dire c'est que si
les gens le font c'est pas qu'ils ont
rien à faire c'est qu'ils ont un don de
mémorisation et il semble que tu es un
don de numérisation dont je me passionne
en tout cas pour mémoriser chose ça
m'intéresse vachement quoi ouais mais
même je me suis je veux je les ai déjà
vus en spectacle
plusieurs fois et que je suis assez
bluffé par sa capacité à mémoriser mais
des trucs et une vitesse incroyable
d'ailleurs j'ai essayé de le faire avec
toi pour la première fois je vais
essayer publiquement en fait de te
montrer comment comment ça marche dans
ma tête et si j'arrive à retrouver une
séquence ou pas tu prends pire où tu
veux ouais tu vas venir une séquence de
cinq chiffres
je vais retrouver l'autre je vais
essayer en fait de compléter si tu me
dis par exemple 5 6 1 9 0 ici il faut
que je te complète d'accord et c'est la
ligue est en dessous pas de l'autre
plage
ouais moi j'ai appris dans ce sens là je
sais vraiment dense 1 cela que je dis
que ça se déroule bien
ok alors si c'est ça marche on est sur
le point de vivre quelque chose
d'exceptionnel quand même un petit
d'erreur oscille sans beaucoup plus
humain finalement 1,1 mais ça me stresse
jeudi jusque là il n'y a pas de trucage
ces jeux c'est vraiment vraiment pas
laquelle choisir comme si je fais des
petites erreurs oui oui mais là déjà
site on trouve
ok alors attention on y va un 3 0 9 6 7
1 3 002 et déjà faut que je le redis ce
que tu reviens sur 1 3 1 3 096 7
c'est impossible
9 6 7 1 3 096 est c'est ce qui va me
prendre le plus de temps c'est de
retrouver aussi d'accord 9,6
7 9 6 7 1 3 096 7,9
ouais 2 5 025 9,7 c'est ça c'est ça
c'est ça j'ai aucune erreur et 2,5 way
we re cette recette 1,3 8,5 g branche
s'attend à devenir un alien 3 1/2
l'attend eric là il ya une erreur à 3 1
4 ouais ouais bah 5 4 5 035 2 1 8 9 et
c'est à mais c'est un grand bravo bravo
c'est incroyable at home tu connais tout
le bouquin bah ouais du coup merci
d'être venu mais merci à toi et ouais
carrément je vois enfin où tu tournes
toutes tes vidéos et ça me tuerait ce
que j'ai envie de dire pourquoi t'as pas
fait vingt mille vidéo pour montrer à
tout le monde que tu sais faire ça c'est
incroyable
mais une vidéo par jour jacques joue
chaque jour il sort un truc comme ça
mais c'est incroyable merci en plus elle
est devenue merci à vous d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo si vous aussi vous amuser à
mémoriser des fois des trucs qui servent
à rien mettez le dans les commentaires
ça me fera plaisir et je me sentirai
beaucoup moins seul moi je mémorise
beaucoup les répliques de films à la
voiture ça n'a pas d'intérêt à la base
réelle
non mais on pourrait croire qu'ils ont
eux mêmes les noms latins les noms
latins de bestioles quand même pas aux
pistes au kobus au hasard ça sert à rien
de le retenir mais moi je sais pas
pourquoi ça veut dire c'est le nom latin
d'un oiseau et de l'oiseau cas les
petites griffes la séance
d'archaeopteryx mais d'aujourd'hui ah
ben tu vois c'est une sorte d'arc et aux
territoires dits savais pas ça
franchement franchement ce genre et
c'est marrant parce qu'on a tous nos
délires manteau en fait mais nous votre
délire mental dans les commentaires on
va on va créer une commune de risques
d'avoir des trucs sur youtube les images
irait
réussi ça m'intéresse pas merci à vous
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo si ça vous a
plu vous nous faites avant laissant un
petit mais néanmoins pisan pouce en
l'air vous pouvez également vous abonner
à la chaîne avant de partir puisque le
mental boxe et une vidéo par jour
pendant un an
donc rendez vous demain à 17h ou 11h gcp
ciao